bonjour monsieur le président merci de
procès de questions une question sur les
mesures prises hier suite au
détournement d'avion en biélorussie cela
fait déjà et moi qui a des dizaines de
dirigeants qui sont sanctionnés en
biélorussie somme serait vraiment en
effet sur une remise en cause du pouvoir
en place vous avez également la
libération de journalistes qui a été
arrêté dimanche dès son franc parler
avec la russie cela faisait des semaines
que l'union européenne réclament la
libération d'alex intérêts des appels
qui restent pour l'instant sans réponse
d'autres on a le sentiment que ces
mesures firmin reste assez faible et
qu'elles n'ont qu'une portée limitée en
quoi vous pensez que les mesures qui ont
été décidées hier on vraiment changer
quelque chose au byblos
merci beaucoup juste pour le club pour
moi vous auriez en tête quel autre type
de mesures
maintenant j'ai côtoyé maintenant j'ai
dit juste pour ce faire pour 3 contre et
vous répondre vous auriez en tête quel
autre titre de mesure là je vous pose la
question c'est juste que c'est juste un
constat
pour lui des mesures qui ont été prises
par le passé on voit que ça n'a pas eu
de conséquences vraiment très concrètes
mais qu'est-ce qui vous apparaît comme
des mesures que je vous dis si on les
vend et pas question les mesures qui
vous apparaîtrait comme beaucoup plus
efficace à l'égard de la biélorussie moi
si c'est moi qui pose la question vous
pose selon vous en quoi vous pensez que
les mesures sont commis hier sont
concrètes lampe pauvre france est calme
ce sont des choix au virus
d'abord c'est sans doute et pas si
évidente de voir des mesures qui serait
beaucoup plus efficace selon conviendrez
avec moi et donc sauf heures à vouloir
entrer dans un jeu plus direct
les mesures de sanction est 700 à la
baule le possible et efficace et le fait
que vous me renvoyez à votre question le
démontre à lui seul deuxième chose nous
avons en effet décidé des sanctions
ciblées et écologique et ça c'est une
montée c'est à dire pas simplement des
sanctions sur quelques dirigeants qui
sont de toute façon confirmé et qui
seront renforcés
mais des sanctions sont des secteurs
économiques qui ont vocation et c'est ce
sur quoi la commission va travailler et
qui sera soumis au nouveau conseil du
trésor et des sanctions qui permettent
justement sur les secteurs tous on est
plus proche du pouvoir et des milieux du
pouvoir d'avoir des conséquences
économiques directes d'après ce que vous
dites est très juste ce que vous dites
est très juste
aussi bien sur la biélorussie que la
russie aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'année
des politiques de sanctions et donc la
question soit plan stratégique ne nous
est proposé simplement quand je vous
renvoie la question c'est pas
le monde parce que je file de fass ici
parce que ça n'est pas évident de dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait derrière mais vous
savez pas lire dans ces cas-là on
déclenche un conflit armé ont
complètement les relations
on a déjà fait on vendra plus loin mais
vers lui c'est ce qui démontre bien
c'est ce couple est d'ailleurs depuis
deux ans plairait que la russie la
politique des sanctions progressives sur
des situations gelé des plus politiques
efficaces et donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a demandé cette revue pour le mois
de juin qui est à mes yeux doit nous
conduire à regarder quel est notre
quelques jours quelle est aujourd'hui la
stratégie de la russie dans la région
et quelle est la réponse efficace des
européens je pense qu'à très court terme
il n'y avait pas de réponse plus
efficace grâce à ce qui s'est passé est
inacceptable en biélorussie et donc
l'enquète de le seuil est déclenchée
je pense que les mesures de restriction
des vols particulier du survol de
l'espace requins sont extrêmement
mordantes sur le système et le russe et
puis enfin des sanctions additionnelles
est ce que cela sera suffisant je ne
sais absolument pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui
je pense que cela aura plus d'impact que
ce qu'on a écrit jusque là parce que
c'est plus dur et le caractère
inacceptable de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche matin de justifie maintenant
comme vous je pense que nous sommes à un
moment de vérité dans notre relation
avec la russie qui doit nous conduire à
repenser les termes de l'attention qu'on
décide pas belle